following the resignation of trade
commissioner phil hogan
meps will express their views on changes
in the commission
parliament is assessing the raid
mcginnis proposed as commissioner for
financial services
and valdis dombrovskis for the trade
portfolio
meps will set their position for goals
in the new climate law
among their demands members want
mandatory eu climate neutrality by 2050
and reduction of 60 of co2 emissions by
2030 compared to 1990 levels
parliament is set to call for a
mechanism to monitor the rule of law
across the eu
also to be debated are rules which would
freeze eu financing to member states
which
don't respect the rule of law forests
are the lungs of europe an essential
part of the green deal and the fight
against climate change
parliament will vote on rules to better
protect europe's forests and promote
their sustainable management
parliament will debate the conclusions
of the special summit of eu leaders
meps will react to council discussions
on the situation in the eastern
mediterranean and relations with turkey
the political impasse in belarus the eu
single market
and the economic recovery
you